hi there today we're looking at dynamic
routing between capsules by saara sabor
Nicholas frost and Geoffrey Hinton of
Google brain this paper is a bit older
but it's made quite the impact at the
time and so we'll go through it I find
this pretty hard paper to read and kind
of understand because a lot of things
are very implicit in hand wavey so we'll
kind of go through it and try to get the
best out of it
try to explain what capsules are and
what they do and how they you know stack
against current networks so capsule
network in essence is a new type of
neural network made of capsules and here
it says a capsule is a group of neurons
whose activity vector represents the
instantiation parameters of a specific
type of entity such as an object or an
object part kind of cryptic but so what
they're saying is that in a capsule
Network let me try to draw one here
actually in a capsule Network you have
what's called capsules capsules you can
imagine as just little blobs of things
right and they're also ordered in layers
in this case let's actually leave away
the second layer and each of these of
these capsules will correspond to an
entity in the input let's say the input
is an image so somewhere here there is
an image right then maybe this capsule
here will be responsible for detecting
is there a wall in the image and this
one will be responsible for detecting is
there a roof and this one will be is
there a door and this one will be
responsible for detecting is there a
lake in the image right so now each of
these each of these capsules can fall on
one hand can either be high or low so if
you if you imagine now as it
we're wall high roof high door hi
Lake low it means probably the image has
a house on it right but second of all
not only can it predict whether or not a
given entity is present in an image but
the individual capsules are also
responsible for encoding the exact way
or shape or form that this entity takes
so the wall could have different aspects
such as color color green
it could have size tall
it could have orientation tation is like
I don't know vertical then roof could
have angle right angle wide so it's a
wide roof for a flat roof right these
are these are kind of attributes of
these things that also the capsules
wouldn't code so ultimately what these
capsules that they are proposing will
output is the roof capsule here for
example would output a vector so the
output of the roof capsule is a and let
me draw a coordinate system is a vector
now the length of the vector will
represent so the the length draw this
norm here will represent the probability
that the roof is in the image okay that
there is a roof in an image right the
roof is element of this input image this
is simply the length and the individual
coordinates will encode these attributes
so this here for example this axis could
be the angle of the roof and this axis
could be the collar let's say just that
the angle is like some degree number
that can be positive or negative maybe a
roof can be like this right this is so
this is
in essence this is a flat roof and this
is a very narrow angle roof so you can
imagine something like this and then the
color could also be maybe parameterised
on a 1-dimensional you can have more
dimensions than - I just can't draw more
so the depending on where this where
this some arrow now points the for
example this vector here has the same
probability that there is a roof in the
image like if the output is this but the
color will be different the angle will
be the same because they're roughly on
the same this axis here but the color of
this will encode a different different
colored roof and then if the vector is
something like this a very short vector
it will encode the same the same angle
and in color directions so maybe I
shouldn't say the position on the axis
it's more like this angle and this this
angle that encode the attributes so the
kind of the angular components if you
will encode the attributes and the
length and coats the probability so this
small vector has the same direction in
terms of color and angle of the roof but
it's much less probable much less likely
so this if the capsule outputs the
little blue vector here it says well if
there is a roof it's going to be this
color in this angle but I'm really
really don't think there's a roof in
this image whereas if it outputs the
large green one then it says I'm pretty
sure that there is a roof and it's going
to be this angle and this this this
angle and this color
alright so that's that's is what each
capsule is supposed to do each capsule
takes the input and outputs a vector
that encodes if the entity that the
capsule is responsible for is present in
the image a and B what properties this
entity has and then we get to the point
where there's the next layer of capsules
so the next layer of capsules takes
information that each capsule here takes
information from each capsule in the
lower layer
like like you're used to from your
neural network and integrates this
information and we'll talk about how
this works it integrates all of this
information right all of these are
vectors now that come from the lower
integrates all of this information and
again each capsule in this next layer is
responsible for a entity now these
entities and the higher layers are
usually composite entities of the lower
layers so this one here could be
responsible for house this one could be
responsible for National Park Park and
this one could be responsible for a
beach or something like this right and
then each of these will integrate all
this information from the lower layers
and then come up with their own output
vector encoding whether or not a given
entity is present in the in the image of
course the house class will pick up if
there is a door or roof and the wall and
the image the house class is will pick
up on that or that's how it's meant to
work house class is meant to pick up on
that and then itself output a large
vector saying there's probably a house
in this in this image so each of these
capsules in by itself is responsible for
encoding the presence and attributes of
a object or object part or entity or
part of entity in the given input data
and of course the last layer here it
will simply be your classification layer
so in the last layer we have as many
capsules as you have classes in your
classification task if so this is mainly
for a classification task and then you
can classify and you can kind of train
the whole system like this so how
exactly this happens we'll see next all
right so they make kind of analogies to
the visual system and so on and we
we'll jump these you can everyone that
have does deep learning in some way is
trying to to make that we're rather
going to the specifics of how these
capsules work and how they're specific
suggestions for them note that they say
this is in no way the only
implementation of capsules is just kind
of an example to show how one could do
it alright so first of all they present
their what you might call non-linearity
so their non-linearity what what it
needs to do is if you look at these
capsule networks the outputs here the
lengths of the outputs of these vectors
right they're supposed to represent
probabilities and as such they they need
to be so here it roof this door may be a
vector like this wall may be a vector
like that so initially if we simply
specify the output is a vector and in
essence these capsules are implemented
in much the same way like your classic
neural networking layer would be
implemented so each of the each of these
each of these capsules will be in
essence a neural network layer by itself
that outputs a a vector and there's
nothing's constraining the length of the
vector initially so their non-linearity
does constrain the vector to be of
maximum length 1 and of minimum length 0
that's this non-linearity here so s here
is the unscaled
output of the capsule and you can see
here if the length of s gets close to 1
or sorry gets really large then this
here is becomes irrelevant this whole
term will be 1 and then the length of
the final output of V here will be 1
right so if this is very large then the
the length of the scale-up will be 1
however if the if the length is really
small of the original output
this base goes towards zero then this
becomes irrelevant this becomes
irrelevant this will go towards zero and
the entire length will go towards zero
so this is kind of a a nice way to scale
these outputs always to be between
length zero and one then next thing is
so how this I find I find the the most
complicated part right so we'll jump
ahead actually to how a capsules network
is implemented and this is the the
capsule network they implement so first
it's an amnesty fire you have an amnesty
image here and it first goes through a
simple convolutional layer that's that
that's nothing new this is a classic
convolutional layer is there's 256
channels it has a nine by nine filters
and stride one so it will output a
twenty by twenty time by 256 tensor then
each of these so each of the outputs
here is sent to each of these capsules
and now their convolutional capsules so
that makes it a bit more complicated but
don't you know don't worry primarily
about them being convolutional capsules
the analogy is exactly as in a classic
neural network you can implement these
capsules as for it feed-forward capsules
or as convolutional capsules and maybe
also as transformer capsules I don't
think anyone's done that all right
there's a paper for you the so you'll
send you'll send the output of this
convolution layer to each capsule and
then you have basically just two layer
of capsules here the first layer
consists of 32 what they call primary
caps sorry the these 32 capsules each
will output
and eight dimensional vector and I'm
simplifying here it's it's convolutional
but they will just first simplest they
will each output an eight dimensional
vector right and these are exactly as we
said before so each of these will really
responsible ultimately for a given
entity or part of entity being there
like an eminence this could be is there
a little curve on the bottom left side
right this might indicate the presence
of a six or an eight something like this
and then the these capsules here is they
represented as a row so each of these
rows here is a capsule and we have ten
of these and these are your simple your
final classification capsules so each
capsule is responsible for indicating
the presence or absence of one
particular class of digits so this we
have a 1 of a 2 of a 3 of a 4 and so on
of a 0 I guess somewhere as well so
these are 10 capsules and the question
is how does information go from a
capsule here from the output of a
capsule or to any of capsule here and
the easy way to do this is simply to say
as in a classical neural network the
output here simply goes to the input
here just you just put it there
basically um um unchanged now if there
is a bit of an issue here with the
dimensions but you can simply say well
we simply put a weight matrix in to
route into the capsules but the idea of
these capsules and this paper is to say
wait wait these capsules actually we
want to make them decide to which
capsule in the next layer will they send
their input right so the capsules can
kind of decide where they want to send
their output to like where is this where
is the capsule that detects the maybe
this one detects is there a line in the
outside of the image right indicating
maybe a 7 or a 1 this is probably most
relevant for the one class and for the 7
class so it might decide to route its
output there and the idea of how this
routing happens is basically the topic
of this paper so the the capsules route
their output to the appropriate next
layers capsules how's this done alright
this is done via the what's called the
routing mechanism I find it quite poorly
described here so I will simply draw it
I will I will simply try to make it up
all right so we have capsules and as
I've drawn them before right we have one
two three capsules and we maybe have two
parent capsules each of these capsules
here will output a vector as we said and
we'll only do it for this this one sorry
vector here so this will output this
vector and needs to decide where to here
or to here to ascend to this output now
what it does is there is an iterative
procedure that has multiple steps and
this is I think this is at least the way
I understand I think the important part
to understand this that if we forward
pass data through this network it
actually doesn't go forward in a
straight line what it actually does is
it goes through a layer and then it does
multiple steps in between layers until
it has decided where it wants to go in
the next layer and then it goes on to
the next layer and if there's another
another capsu layers it does again
multiple steps before it goes on so
that's that's my take on it and the
multiple steps are as follows first I'll
send my output vector to to all of the
all of their layers like equally all of
the
capsules and so will will everyone else
right everyone will send theirs equally
to the parent now this isn't just done
and this may be here this isn't just
done just by sending it but this is
actually done by modulation of weight
matrices so each thing here if this is
capsule I and this is capsule J there is
a weight matrix in between W IJ that is
learned right this is a static weight
matrix and each one of these red hat red
arrows you see here has such a weight
matrix attached to it so each each line
you see here is actually modulated by
such a weight matrix so there is an a
quadratic number of these weight
matrices flying around and this will
also then allow you that maybe this
vector is eight dimensional about the
input vector here are 16 dimensional
what we saw before all right so the out
the input of capsule J here it will
receive let's see what it receives it
will receive the output of cap so will
the output of capsule R 1 V 1 modulated
by the that's let's call this let's call
this J modulated by 1 j w 1j and it will
also receive this as a set the output of
capsule two modulated by the weight
matrix for a sorry weight matrix for
capsule 2 and so on now what it does is
it adds this these all up into a softmax
so sorry let's write this so soft it
will add those all up in a soft max
weighted fashion so it will actually
compute a a weighted average of those
now the weights at the beginning are are
just 1 because it gets each from each
lower capsular gets equal amount of this
vector but then this will give you an
output so this will give you some output
let's put this in green this will give
you an output that's I don't know how
they call it in a paper let's just call
it Oh Jay right and then what you do is
all right
you compare how much do each of the
individual contributions agree with OJ
so you actually compute for each of
these you would compute the inner
product so you could compute the inner
product of w1 j v1 with LJ and you would
compute the inner product of w 2j v2
with o.j
all right the inner product and then
these inner products here will become
the weighting coefficients for the
softmax in the next iteration all right
so this I mean this this is a bit
convoluted but ultimately what you're
saying is if you're a capsule here
you'll send your output forward you have
an output you send it forward right to
the other capsule and the other capsule
will so if this is this is your output
and we'll forget about this weight
matrix for now this is Europe the other
capsule will output its own its own
output computed from the lower layers
now we do it in iteration again if your
output now aligns with this you will
send more of it and these two that I've
drawn here actually aligned pretty well
right so you'll send more of it more and
more more right and now maybe the output
the next computed output of the same
capsule will be even more in that
direction because you've contributed
more right you'll send more and then you
like in the next iteration valleys to a
really equal sorry this should be red
here your ears just keeps being the same
and then you say well I'm gonna set even
more to that one right whereas another
capsule
that it's whose initial output was
basically whose initial output was
basically like this it will by itself
compute the inner product with the
original dis written it will send it
here right it will compute the inner
product with the original output and it
will realize well these do not align
very much and then it will send less
right it will ascend less to the next
step and because it sends less in the
next step of course the output will then
probably align even less with that
vector and then it will send less and
less and less so this is called dynamic
routing the the idea behind it is kind
of that you route by agreement so you
will route to the parent capsules that
agree with your output and by agreement
we mean kind of the inner product as
high after modulating by this weight
matrix and that sort of so that
basically means this weight matrix is
responsible for deciding which
information is relevant together
whenever you have two vectors that align
in the same layer then the in the sense
of the capsule networks those represent
the same kind of information and those
will be routed together to the same
capsule in terms of the examples we made
maybe if a door and the roof is present
then these these these weight matrices
that connect door and roof to the house
class they will transform a high vector
and door and groove into aligning
vectors for the house class and thereby
saying look these two if I look at them
through if I look at a door and a roof
through the perspective of trying to be
a house right then they are in much
agreement on the presence of a house so
if I am a house
right I am a house and I look at a door
and I look at a roof through the planner
from the perspective of being a house
right this is this is what these weight
matrices do they always have a
perspective of the parent capsule then
these two things they make a lot of
sense together and thus I will route
them to the same place so they can both
contribute to their being a house now
from the perspective of a house if I
look at a little beach with a tree on it
right then that does not that is not the
same that does not really is not the
same information as a door or a roof so
I will not route this to the house in
the in the same strength that is sort of
the best way I have of explaining it how
these capsules work basically the lower
entities will always be routed for the
relevance of the higher entities that
are trying to they're trying to combine
the lower entities if that wasn't it's
not entirely clear to me either yet but
it's the best job I I can give the
routing is here formalized I I find it
hard to follow the important thing is
that there is an inner loop in all of
this
so there is an LOC and even an inner
iteration and this inner iteration is
computed in every forward pass and so
these routing where the information goes
in the next layer that is only the prior
probability for that is learned but the
actual routing coefficients those are
dynamically computed in every forward
pass so every forward pass goes it goes
information goes through a layer then it
goes multiple steps between two layers
until it decides exactly what the
distribution for the next layer is and
then the next layer computes its outputs
and that goes again multiple steps
between these layers and the next layer
so that's the the basic thing to
remember there's also some normalization
and well if the squash is the
non-linearity we discussed so whether
they actually train now at the end here
they have a they have these ten capsules
and each capsule will be responsible for
recognizing one the presence of one
digit in the M&S dataset of course and
so what they do is they take the length
of these vectors that are output by
these capsules these capsules are
feed-forward capsules as opposed to the
convolutional capsules here so the
feed-forward capsules output again a
vector the length of this vector is
taken and then it's basically trained
like you would train a regression
problem and the loss here is specified
up here so if the if the image actually
does contain this if the training label
actually has this digit present this T
here encodes that so if K let's say K is
2 right so if K 2 if there is a 2 in the
image when we know that because it's a
training image then the length of the
output of capsule number 2 should be
high and this simply encodes that it
should be very close to this M plus and
M plus here is say I think they set it
to 0.9 so they say you should be the
length should be as close as possible to
0.9 whereas if the two is not present
then TK will be 0 then this part will be
active so it's only one of these two
parts will be active then the length of
the vector so of capsule number two
should be close to this M negative which
is zero point one it's basically a
regression problem saying eh
if there if the given entity is in the
image then please make the length as
close as possible to 0.9 and if it's not
make it as close as possible to 0.1 so
this this is a classic say regression
loss on the length of the output vectors
the the lambda is just a factor to do
dampen the contribution for all the
negative classes or with respect to the
one positive class of course per capsule
it turns out this is actually not enough
so this will be the classification
output but it's it seems not enough they
don't say it's not enough but they
simply say we additionally do the
following so they also do is they
introduce a reconstruction loss now if
this model is trained correctly then
these capsules here these last capsules
especially this one
maybe that's the capsule corresponding
to the class of the digit 8 will not
only encode if an 8 is there or not as
in the length of the vector output but
it will also encode the properties of
the 18 it's a 16 dimensional vector so
it will encode hopefully things like the
stroke width so then it might encode the
may be the rotation of the digit then it
might be controlled the tightness of the
of the loop so you can have an 8 with
very large loops or it can have an 8 oh
sorry this is a small rate I can have an
8 with very tight loops so it might you
know encode things like this so
technically it is it will be possible to
reconstruct from this description
reconstruct a the width is high the
rotation is 0 and the tightness is low
then maybe I have a a wide widely
stroked not tight 8 that is not
Tainted right so it should be possible
to reconstruct this and they do exactly
that so they take this last capsule of
the class that is the actual training
label that's called the reconstruction
target and they feed this to a simple
feed-forward neural network that at the
end you see this is exactly the EM nest
size we'll try to reconstruct the image
so if the image here this image goes in
then it goes all through here it will
take the class for here feed it through
this network reshape it to an image
again and hopefully what will come out
is again this four here and it will then
have an auxiliary auxiliary loss in
addition to the loss of this of this
classification loss here will auxiliary
loss that tries to reconstruct the
original image right and that's simply a
I believe it's just an l2 reconstruction
loss that is that is scaled down that it
doesn't dominate so they also train the
network basically to reconstruct this
and I believe they do this because the
length isn't quite enough to make it do
what they want it to do
thus they by having this reconstruction
here they really kind of enforce that
the individual capsules the individual
dimensions must encode some kind of
information about the original image and
since the original images in the amnesty
ADA said at least vary by those things
by stroke width by rotation by tightness
that by this loss will be reflected in
the in the reconstruction
all right so how are they doing here you
see different examples of inputs and
then reconstructed outputs and this you
know seems pretty good actually
so you see here all of these the input
image is reconstructed fairly well so
the numbers up here in the phones on the
right are the failure cases here it the
input image is a five labeled in the
training data but the network actually
classifies it as a three but then if you
now you have two choices right this this
is the same sample I have two choices
for reconstruction either you
reconstruct the capsule that is actually
the is that you know is the true capsule
that should be activated and you
reconstruct from that or you reconstruct
from the capsule that the network says
that it classifies it as so here it
mixed up of five four three if you still
take the five that capsule and
reconstruct it you see it actually looks
like the original image but it looks
much more like a five and if you take
the three capsule to reconstruct which
is what the network classified this as
it still it looks like the originals but
it looks much more like an actual three
right it's missing the the part up here
whereas over here it's it's missing this
part here so the the network really
seems to kind of learn the different
variations of these digits and in an
ambiguous case such as this one it you
know it can you can actually go either
way and it can actually reconstruct the
original output in either
interpretations at once as a three in
once as a five it will be interesting to
see what the actual length of the vector
of both of these classes were that were
mixed up here they compare their
accuracies so they have a baseline model
which I believe is just like CNN where
they get a decent kind of error and then
capsule networks they get a lower error
and here you see as you add the
reconstruction loss and as you add
routing more so one step of routing
simply means the first step is where you
send your output equally to each parent
that is as in the classical neural
network case but if you introduce three
steps of routing then your error drops
even lower so they kind of are on par
with baseline CNN's on M nest here they
also explore what their capsules learn
so as I said the individual capsules the
dimensions should encode kind of
properties of the variations of the of
the class class samples and here they
explore this in the different capsules
so they change some dimensions and they
run it through their reconstruction
networks and indeed they discover that
there is like a scale and thickness
dimension stroke thickness dimension
there's a skew dimension and so on width
and translation so that that this is a
pretty remarkable these networks really
if you train them in this way they
really seem to learn about the entities
and about the properties of the entities
and that seems to be quite interesting
you see that there's everything here
stays well within the class that the
capsule is assigned to they also have
this robustness to affine
transformations where they improve over
the baseline it's kind of an auxiliary
experiment the next interesting
experiment is what they call the multi M
NIST experiment the multi analyst
experiment is done by taking two
different amnesty digits and basically
just overlapping them so that they have
you know shift them slightly but as you
see here or here they are overlapped
heavily
the task of the network is to figure out
which two overlapping digits are in the
image and the the network is very very
good at doing this the capsule network
that is and better than the base lines
because the capsule network simply
encodes the presence and properties of a
particular instance in the image if you
simply take the top two length capsules
and then reconstruct those independently
then your you can you can are you can
basically segment the image and you see
this here so the different colorations
come from two different reconstructions
of the image from two different capsules
so a green is from one capsule and red
from the other capsule so the network
correctly identifies that it's a six and
is zero right and it also correctly
identifies not only which pixels belong
to the six and which belong to zero but
also pixels that belong to both so
that's not a not a problem if you use
capsule networks as they are are notable
to say here they the way they train is
is they train the actual reconstruction
by only reconstructing one at a time
so the kind of the premise of the
dataset is that you actually have access
to the underlying individual digits
while training so you like the images of
the individual digits you don't know not
only have this this label here but
that's a detail here are some kind of
failure cases where it it misclassified
or you may specify the capsules and it's
kind of unable
use here you see to to assign the digits
of the misclassified or the pixels of
the misclassified thing now it's quite
interesting to look at the failure cases
but I find it more interesting to look
at actually the success cases and the
kind of ease at which the at which the
capsu networks can do this simply by how
they're structured
all right so then lastly they also
experiment on C 410 and interestingly
the C 4 10 experiments show that the
capsule networks don't perform as well
there and as you know C 410 is a dataset
that is about the same size as endless
but it's the first of all colorants
involves natural images and so they have
quite a bit of clutters it's not black
and white black background white digits
it's actually there's a sky and icon and
in an image there is lots of things
going on and right there's my tree and
there's stuff here and there stuff here
and the the caption networks they like
to account for things in the image so
they like to have a capsule
corresponding to everything that's going
on here and here and here and here and
here and if the whole background is
black that is not a problem you can
account for simply the the background
but if there's lots of things going on
then these capsule networks get they get
they get a bit over explanatory they
want to explain everything and that
degrades the performance now this paper
basically says yeah you can have a
something like a none of the above
category and they found that it helps
you introduce that in my opinion that it
I think the the the solution will be
more towards introduction of a better
loss function for this because like such
that you don't need kind of to explain
the entire thing rather than here well
here what you do is you simply explain
it by saying it's none of the above but
it's incredibly hard to balance that my
opinion all right so that is basically
the end of this they say they have a
discussion here where they compare
capsules against other related work but
I hope that you kind of got an overview
of how this works now and
as much as possible and we thought that
was it from me and thanks for watching
bye